foreign
let's go to uh Rachel in Manchester
New Hampshire what's up Rachel
hi Dr John how are you so good how are
you
I'm doing well thank you a little
nervous but uh grateful to be on the
show awesome thanks for joining us
what's up
um so my question is excuse me um how do
I raise my children to live in this
technology focused Society without
allowing them to become upset
hmm
I don't know you told me you tell me I'm
trying to figure that out myself I don't
know what to do
um tell me about your kids and tell me
what you're struggling with
um so my husband and I are expecting our
first child in December so we don't have
any children right now
um but we've been you know listening to
you and Dave Ramsey and we've been
talking about what we want our uh family
values to be and a big one is you know
not being so obsessed with their phones
that they will inevitably have
eventually and to value
human to human contact and interaction
this one this one's actually easy Rachel
easy okay you called the right guy
um because I'm an addict when it comes
to my phone and so it's something I've
had to just deal with like I would if I
was addicted to alcohol
um
your kids your first kid your second kid
your third kid are going to find out the
way the world works by watching you and
your husband
okay and so if you want to create a
world where phones are not the
centerpiece of that world
at least until they get into grade
school
make phones like a screwdriver it just
stays in the drawer it's a tool that we
use when we need it ta-da
and your kids will not even understand
that's part of the world now here's a
couple of caveats to that
um when my son was born my wife and I
were Maniacs because it was right when
iPads were coming out everywhere and
cell phones were just ever I mean there
and I it just felt wrong I I just
something about it wasn't right probably
in retrospect it was just because I was
afraid of change
um and I was using these Cavalier we're
all going to die probably very similar
to the guy that was in charge of a horse
farm and then all of a sudden Henry Ford
started driving model T's everywhere and
he's like you know what's gonna happen
right so there we go
but my son one time he was two
um and he was late to speak he was very
late to be fluent but I remember we sat
down in a restaurant and he looked at we
had a laminated uh menu and he they sat
it down and he started dropping his
fingers trying to expand the menu
as though it was like you know like a
cell phone trying to make the picture
bigger
and both me and my wife looked at each
other he did not he had never seen us do
that that was not from our house he'd
pick that up somewhere just in passing
whether that was at the supermarket or
somewhere at a family gathering so
they're gonna pick it up they're gonna
see it
but they're going to learn how to live
with your values by watching how you and
your husband live your values
and then when they get to elementary
school my son was in fifth grade and I
think he was the only one maybe one
other kid didn't have already have a
smartphone and all that stuff so it will
happen early
and it's just gonna be like everything
else whether it's I have to have the
right tennis shoes or I got to have the
right Gadget or I gotta have the right
um why I don't have the right you know
bat bag for the baseball team you're
going to be fighting that that's just
human nature kids want to fit in and
they want to be like their friends and
they want to be cool and that's not
weird that's normal that's Developmental
and sometimes we can't afford certain
things and so we're going to teach them
about realities of money and sometimes
I'm not going to buy you a 400 or 100
pair of jeans because you gross seven
inches every week and so like right some
of those natural conversations phones
are just gonna be a part of that
conversation too
right yes all your friends has it and
have them and I my job is to keep your
mind safe and they're not good for you
and so we're not gonna do that in my
house ta-da and my son I've talked about
on the show but he called me on it once
and he was right
um as he was entering middle school
because he's on his only kid you know
that has doesn't have some access to
some kind of phone and he said dad you
took away the phone fine you say that
these things aren't good for me and my
you know fine but I got nothing
and when my friends come over no video
game like we've got nothing and he was
right and so I went I I went and we
moved some budget stuff around and I
bought a foosball table and I bought
like an air hockey table off Amazon had
it shipped to the house and I got him a
bow and arrow like I got him some things
to do that he could go do with his
friends that he could do by himself that
didn't involve so he called me on the
carpet and he was right I had to provide
some alternative activities for him that
were different
um and now we've got a cool thing to do
we go out in the front yard and shoot
our arrows and we man you talk about
some trash talking in the deloney house
when we're playing air hockey together
right you see what I'm saying so I even
had to adapt and learn and get some new
things and learn some new things and we
were in a financial position to do that
but we got the cheapest ones we could
because we're going to destroy them
because that's the house that we have
um is that helping
yeah no absolutely yeah we've heard you
um as I said both of us listen to your
show so we've heard you talk about how
you
don't prioritize cell phones and devices
at home and you have other means of you
know giving your kids things to do when
these days everyone just shoves them in
front of a TV screen here's one of my
operating rules whenever a child walks
into a room I put whatever screen I'm
looking at down
even if I tell them hey I'm in the
middle of sending a text message I need
you to wait a minute that's okay hey I'm
in the middle of working on a work email
right now I need you to give me two
minutes okay
um most of the time I'm just mindlessly
scrolling like an idiot and it's good
that I put the phone down
but that's one of our rules I want my
kids to know you are more important than
whatever flashy thing is in front of me
that makes complete sense and
I will challenge any parent I can be
wrong here I don't think I am
your kids cannot compete with the the
psychologist and neurobiologist and tech
companies who have all joined forces to
create the single most addictive device
that's ever existed
they can't compete and so to hand that
to a sixth grader or to a ninth grader
and say well you only get 30 minutes
is like handing cocaine to a kid and
saying you only get to do a little bit
right it's just not it's just it's just
not fair it's not it's not it's not
um Integris because it's impossible
you're lighting up a kid's brain like a
Christmas tree and then you're going to
hold them accountable when you can't pay
attention when he gets fidgety when she
just wants to grab the phone grab the
phone and grab the phone
that's not I mean you can't do that man
you can't give a kid cocaine and get mad
at them because they're running around
the house
you can't do that right so I I've I may
be proven wrong and I may be like you
know what son I screwed this up but my
Approach is as little as as humanly
possible
because they're already getting it
everywhere and by the way my son now
he's in middle school and you know every
school's got computers and all that dude
he can fly around a computer now
it took him like one second and so this
idea that they're going to be behind
they're not going to be digitally native
not dude they're so intuitive and we as
a society have no idea I keep pretty
close tabs on the AI world
what's coming
holy smokes dude we're about to be
living in a Sci-Fi movie in a profound
way and so I'm not worried at all about
the intuitive nature of Technology
integration
it's common sister it's coming and so
screens will be I think lower on on the
on the priority list in the coming years
okay okay I think this stuff is going to
be so integrated and braided into our
lives that um
keeping them from a phone will be the
least of our challenges and that's okay
I I welcome what AI can can bring to us
and what what advances it will help us
as a
Society
um and I could get off the rails and
Terminator 2 could actually happen right
um but Rachel remember these things
these two important things they're
watching everything you do
they're watching everything you do and
when a kid walks in the room the screens
go down I think starting there is a
great place and congratulations to you
and your husband for thinking through
what kind of parents do we want to be
what what's our picture of what our home
is going to look like and let's reverse
engineer that early on so that that
picture comes true good for you Rachel